she left on the last Salam alaikum peace
be with you thank you for tuning in to
this week's show we got Christopher
Pavlovich in the studio this is a
brother who accepted Islam from creation
background and a hamdullah he's here to
tell us his story fell off for some time
and that's what makes it unique where
many people they come to the realization
that there is a purpose to life they
find it out in Islam and they start
living it and then the desires take over
you know friends and family difficulties
and sometimes people fall back to their
routines that they develop bad habits
for four years and now he came back and
hummed lost so we're going to share his
story with you and benefit from his
story and see how he actually drifted
away and how he came back it's a really
really incredible show don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
this is the this is the video this is
the days of the theme you know this is
the things you wanna go to you jew
christopher pavlicek yes how are you
doing brother how I'm good I'm good I'm
good I'm glad to be here glad to have
you here and we pavlicek so this is a
Croatian your mother's Croatian and your
father is from my father my father's
side we're bohemian so that's where the
pavlicek comes yeah but on the mother's
side yet with Croatian now that's a you
know really unique you we have so many
people we know Islam is the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
and so many people are realizing that
there's more to life than just partying
in play and you know making money and
you actually realize that at a young age
at the age of 15 is that right yeah
that's right I I first got interested in
Islam and mid mid 90s early 90s you know
in hip-hop music and the media and the
movies Islam was portrayed in a good
light at those times so I kept hearing
about it I got interested in it a few
things in my life made me really think
you know actually search for a true path
so the more I looked into Islam the
concept of one God it was like
everything I was looking for the idea
that you know we all of our worship goes
to one Lord and there's not you know
three in one or you know different types
of God's different you know ways to
worship that there's there's one true
path that uh that brought a certain
degree a piece to my life even at a
young age yeah let's talk about we're
going to talk about something that you
know stands out especially in the
European community
and and some other communities people
aren't used to hear you know we have a
melting pot in the United States and
people don't really focus too much on
these things but back in the European
community Bosnian community Croatian
community when they see such a nice
beard like yourself they it stands out
so people want to know like usually if
you we mentioned that Croatian
background but now some people think
okay why does he have a beard you know
did he become an Arab what have you ever
had someone questioned you about your
beard yeah even the beard and then just
becoming Muslim in general people will
say to you like all you becoming an Arab
now or you're becoming an Indian or in
my case you know I I started growing the
beard because i found that that's one of
the attributes of the prophet muhammad
saw some peace be upon him and then the
other prophets as well any time you look
in you know Christian or Jewish theology
you see the portraits that they have of
the prophets are always with beards you
know it's a it's a sign of masculinity
so even without knowing all the
scientific benefits which are being you
know brought to us now you know I I did
it to look like a Muslim to resemble
those prophets knowing that you know
they're the best of mankind yeah the
world observer talking about science
this is really interesting I mean we
don't actually grow it because of
science but we see a lot of the things
that the craters told us to do it's a
benefit for us and there are so many big
things small things and now let's say
for the beard I just want to bring this
point the world observer they actually
published an article talking about this
is from a study done at the University
of Southern Queensland it was published
in the radiation protection protection
dosimetry journal now they found this
this is them speaking now they found in
this study that the beard one that
you're the beautiful one year you're
wearing mashallah they said that the
beard it blocks ninety to ninety percent
of UV rays it's a cancer-fighting I'd be
protecting you from the UV rays
obviously that caused cancer and and and
it goes on to say that the beard also
along with slowing down the aging
process
reducing the risk of skin cancer all
from the beard talks about you got
asthma you know the pollens and dust
simply get stuck in the facial hair of
the beard so also protecting you and
keeping you looking young and fresh so
this is from a scientific perspective
that's really unique to hear something
like that isn't it it's great to know
it's great to know it's great to know I
think maybe that's encouragement for
some of our brothers who might not be at
the beard level yet now it doesn't stop
there it talks about you know continuing
on it talks about you know the study the
researchers also they mention that
shaving usually causes ingrown hairs and
the bacterial infections that lead to
acne so now for the people shaving it
talks about shaving usually causes
ingrown hairs and which leads to
bacteria and infections leading to add
to the to the acne so there's actually
in the study the the shaving is actually
bad for you so sorry so so so hopefully
for the people that got just stuck on
the beard now you know we can kind of
you know move along yeah from there you
can move on from my beard yeah anyways
so continue on so now you're a young man
around 50 is that right at 15 years of
age you accepted Islam yeah about well I
grew up on the north side of Chicago and
we wound up inheriting my grandmother's
house in Naperville and when we move to
naperville the community was totally
different than rogers park where I grew
up you know I Rogers Park is very
diverse part of chicago it's like the
United Nations naperville was not like
that at that time it was very uh you
know one type of people out there so it
was kind of difficult for me to fit in
it first and I found myself doing things
that I didn't like to do I was doing
some bad stuff for sure I was being the
bad kid because coming from Chicago all
the kids looked at me as like oh you
know Chicago's dangerous and you're
gonna get into trouble and all that so I
I body
to be cool with everybody to be popular
so I played you know the bad guy role
and just to make friends but that wasn't
me not I don't have that make up I'm not
a bad guy so I was just pretending to be
somebody for them and this is that a
young young age this is like eighth
grade freshman year of high school so it
wasn't me I didn't feel comfortable so I
started searching and while I'm making
that search schools going over the
Middle East schools going over Africa
the news like I said before news is
talking about a few boards that are like
hit close to home because at that time
was the Bosnian words I'm sure you know
and all Bosnians equations are
essentially the same people just a
different side of the border so there's
that and there's a war in Chechnya which
is close to my other side so it's LOM
just kept coming into my life everywhere
I would you know look at the news if I
listen to the music I listened to they
would be you know seeing assalamualaikum
later and stuff to that extent so it
just kept coming at me schools going
over it I decided to study more and the
more I studied about sociology and
history Islam just kept coming at me so
eventually I came to the conclusion that
i'm going to become muslim because it
just seems right worship one god what
could be more simpler than that it's me
and my Creator so we had a nice high
school student that decided to talk
about islam for the class and they gave
a little presentation these are the
pillars of islam this is he-man and this
is what the muslims believe and by the
by that time I had already decided I'm
going to become Muslim so I wrote the
question down like how do I become
Muslim and next thing I know I get a
phone call from the local Imam let's
hold right there do you get a phone call
from the local Imam they're saying that
we got to go to break so it almost your
place we're going to hear the rest of
the story also going to be talking about
a former fighter with the UFC who also
accepted Islam all of that and more here
in the D show will be right back so who
Allah who say he allows one God is
the maker of mankind exactly a lot was
somewhat lost self-sufficient he doesn't
need food or drink he doesn't need to
rest on the seventh day ok I really had
a problem with that even before i do
anything about Islam God resting sounds
like a week guy yeah lamb me I'll it
when I'm you let he begets not he
doesn't have any children nor was he a
child were born of anything or anyone
well I'm ya khuda na hoku fly and
there's nothing cold feet or comparable
to him at all nobody nothing Jesus no
nobody nobody is comparable to the
crater nothing yeah and that right there
was in his essence what I believe
naturally
back here on the Dean show with
Christopher Pavlovich Havlicek Havlicek
you know my front and my friends and
guests will become my friends they know
many people been on the Dean show I
usually mess up some names in the first
time so please forgive me now let's
continue on so Islam is hitting you from
all over the place okay it's like signs
are coming to you and you're at that
point are you are you starting to get a
little more like serious in life or were
you thinking about what's the purpose of
life were you what was your state at
that time in life when these signs are
coming to you like right so so these
things are coming at me from every angle
from visible from the television from
audio from the music i'm listening to
and then it's hitting me now you're in
class right and now you you have someone
doing a presentation and what happens
from there cuz you're on right they they
as you could imagine the speaker takes
questions so I wrote down the question
how does one you know become Muslim yeah
so what she did is she turn the
information over to the local Imam of
the message there's a nice message at
their neighborhood actually there's a
few now but I'm dating myself at that
time there was one calls me up he says
you know I understand that you would
like to become Muslim and at this point
you know I've made the decision really
based on the the most basic simple
explanation of Islam that they worship
one God and not much else so he talks to
me over the phone he says do you believe
you know that there's only one guy do
you believe that Muhammad is the
Messenger and he runs down the list of
the beliefs that a Muslim should have I
just agree to everything because my
heart is already telling me you're gonna
become Muslim that's it I'm not I'm
young I'm not doing the deep research
that somebody that might be in their 20s
or 30s is going to do I'm barely a
teenager but something inside of me is
just driving me that this is you know
this is the right path this is what you
got to do and I had that moment that a
lot of people that embrace Islam will
talk about I said you know by myself at
one point and I just said you know
whoever is above whoever is the one that
controls all this way if it's Jesus if
it's a law guidance send me send me in
the right direction somewhere and all
this took place right then
it was a miracle like Islam just became
exposed to me in a place where there's
hardly any Muslims to begin with yeah so
now you come in from a Christian
background someone says hold on you keep
stressing the belief in one God but if a
Christian watching says no not we what
did you do how did you do it anything
different because we as Christians we
believe in one God also right and and
that's something that a lot of people
are confused about because they say no
we only worship one God but at the same
time then who what is Jesus role in your
religion that's what Jesus is God know
that that's where that's where the
confusion will hit me and that's why I
couldn't accept it because Jesus is
either the Son of God or he's a part of
God or he's a separate entity and we
pray to God and that confusion that they
ambiguity if you will that that just
didn't make sense to me and I could
never accept that that Jesus was
actually a part of God right and what do
you believe is a Muslim 9 and obviously
a Muslim is simply one like Jesus and
Abraham Moses Jesus wasn't a Christian
he was one who submitted to the will of
God Jesus submitted to Allah Abraham all
the prophets including Mohammad being
the last they all submitted to the
creator so that's what a Muslim is but
what what what what do you say now to
the person who is stuck between ok do I
worship Jesus but I worship and that's
what the problem you had right with the
whole Trinity thing right well what was
it now about Islam it's just the belief
just worship the crater yeah in islam
it's as simple as you can be and as
Muslims we believe in the revelation
that came to Noah and Abraham and Moses
and Jesus was basically the same
revelation to worship one God and even
in the Old Testament and the New
Testament now you see that Jesus is
praying to God Moses is praying to God
Abraham is praying the guard so why now
am I going to pray to Jesus rather than
do what Jesus did which is pray to God I
couldn't get past that point and that's
another aspect of Islam's that we love
all of these prophets to a level that
they're human beings but they're not
godlike
they're the best of mankind and they
came with the revelations for us you
know they're the example to be followed
hence you know our beards that's one
aspect that we're following them but to
raise them to a level that they never
even rose themselves to it never SAT
well with me and that tradition
obviously the greatest thing that we do
in following them is worshipping like
Jesus worshipped like Abraham they
didn't worship Jesus they worship the
creator of Jesus correct right in the
greetings we greet each other with peace
peace be unto you that's right is also
mentioned in the Bible that Jesus
greeted his followers with peace and the
way he prayed he fasted he went to they
did the pilgrimage to the Bible's called
Becca which is Mecca is that right so
that's the five pillars that's Islam
submission to the will of God so now in
Islam it's just worshiping the crater
not the creation it's clear it's simple
one and you move out any any divinity
next to god so there's no holy son or
holy holy ghost it's just God right one
God that's it that all Trinity that's it
no no no need for any additives or
preservatives that's it we mentioned now
a former UFC fighter and he's actually a
really incredible individual his name is
are going on relic relish and he's
actually one of my black belts black
bill under me and thank God that he also
he's Croatian and I thought about
mentioning him because your mother's
Croatian I believe his mother is also
creation he recently you met him down at
where you guys will be were in New
Jersey at the New Jersey well he
actually after that meeting with him in
New Jersey he actually accepted Islam
and I wanted to also talk about before
we go into the rest of your story many
people that are they don't understand
that you can still remain Croatian the
Serbian you know whatever your
nationality is you still remain Greek
but now if you become a Muslim that
doesn't change any other can you can you
talk about because you you didn't that
you didn't stop being Croatian no no
that that's a common misconception is
that you know Islam as it is in America
there's a great wave of immigrants that
have come here from the Middle East from
Africa and whatnot so so that's what the
people see but they don't realize that
it's a faith it's not a cultural thing
so for a person from Nigeria to be a
Muslim is no different than our brother
that you mentioned from Croatia being a
Muslim because it's the faith it's what
you believe on the inside mm-hmm so now
for someone like God on yourself you
know you accept Islam did you have a lot
of resistance from family from old
friends the resistance that I
experienced was was from a lack of
knowledge you know it wasn't like hatred
but yeah my father thought you know now
you're going to become an Arab that's he
literally told me that and it's just
because people don't know they don't
they don't have the knowledge to
separate the religion from the culture
that a lot of people have we're going to
take a break and we will continue on and
wrap things up here with Christopher
story on how he came to Islam and then
we're also going to get in how you kind
of drifted away and then end up coming
back this is very common also today
we're going to also benefit from his
experiences here on the Dean shell
you when I embrace the slam from that
day on I knew I never wanted to drink
another drink in my life I never wanted
to smoke I never wanted to earn my body
because I realized that it was a
blessing you know to be able to see life
from the perspective of Islam because
it's like a lens that clarifies life for
you and so I started seeing the clarity
of life and I said this is what I've
been looking for all my life now all I
have to do is live up to it jihad often
mistranslated as holy war the word jihad
means to struggle Islam does not preach
violence it does not preach vicious holy
war it certainly does not condone terror
and suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam order your free copy of the
Koran today back here on the Dean show
and tell us now okay so you you accepted
the mom he calls you you accept Islam
what do you have to do to accept Islam I
have to bear witness that there is no
god but allah and that muhammad is his
last and final messenger so that was
easy for me to do i did it over the
phone as a matter of fact that was
that's it that's it I someone hearing a
law for the first time they think okay
this is you know some some some god of
the Arabs right ready you say just
because it's an Arabic word but no this
is just the name for like the Supreme
God the Almighty God you know you could
translate it in different ways but we're
basically talking about the one who
created everything is in control of all
the affairs yeah so we say Allah you
could you could find people that would
say different than that but we say a lot
is Muslims Jews and Christians who are
Arabic speaking they also who are
Christians that's right but they're from
the Arab area they speak they say a lot
don't they yes they do okay so now you
bear witness that there's nothing worth
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator in Arabic Allah and Muhammad
is the last and final messenger now this
would obviously include all as soon as
you make this statement how does Jesus
mozem how do they all fit in there are
also messages so you believe in all of
them off absolutely
yeah absolutely you can't be a Muslim
without accepting them yeah that's deep
so now you accept you accept Islam now
the rest of the story you kind of
drifted off there are so many people
this is in your nature to worship the
crater not the creation to bear witness
to this to acknowledge you know that hey
this creation is not purposeless there's
a purpose behind it and I'm going to
worship anything is going to be money
sticks stones or both is going to be the
one who created mankind so now you bear
witness to that but you kind of drifted
off tell us about that yeah well as I
explained you know the concept of
worshiping one God that's I think that's
an innate quality you know I think the
majority of mankind they have that built
into him so they're gonna do that and I
accepted that easily but what happened
to me after that is I'm 15 I'm 16 years
old I'm in high school I wound up moving
back towards the city because things
things got a little difficult with my
family so it was easier for me to live
with my grandparents on the southwest
side once I got there are just the
average high school of life you know a
teenager's life your own dating partying
I was overwhelmed by it so knowing that
it's wrong to do it and actually like
believing it's wrong to do it are two
different things so yeah I fell into I
fell into the clubs and I fell into
gangs and everything you know that comes
with that the quest for money the quest
for power all of that you know that
became real exciting you know you see
somebody with a fancy car you want to be
like them and if you're if you're in an
environment where that's kind of looked
at is like the top level that that's the
best you can do then you pursue it and
you pursue it and that's what I did I
went and I got involved in that
lifestyle and you know a lot of people
that I met in that lifestyle I look back
now sadly this is why I'm active and our
now because there's a lot of people that
are like 2nd 3rd 4th generation
gangbangers in the city of Chicago you
know it's kind of a unique thing that we
have the other cities don't have and I
just find people like a good honest
person but they're born into it so I was
exposed to a lot of
people like that then I met some people
that I swear with like the smartest
people I've ever met but they're born
into that lifestyle and for them to get
out of it they have to be exposed to
Islam or exposed to a better way of life
to know that that's not everything there
is so this LOM provides that alternative
definitely now yeah I'm sorry but it
provides you with that piece mm-hmm it
provides you with the ability to just
sit down and relax and not be looking
over your shoulder and every time you
know you hear a siren where if that's
your door that they're coming too so
it's LOM gives you that peace and that's
the key man and as others before me and
as I'm sure there's some people out
there now you know you you're coming
close to rock bottom and in my case rock
bottom was a note getting detained and
going through circumstances that could
have you know put me behind bars for a
very long time but at that point just
like a lot of people you find God I
found a lot again I came back to Islam
again because I knew I had no
alternatives I had nothing to help me
I'm I'm in bars yeah and I know I don't
have anybody that's gonna look out for
me except a lot so that dramatic
experience will bring you back to Islam
and it happened to me before it was too
late yeah I have other friends that they
didn't get that opportunity and a lot
took them back earlier yeah so they took
them back by by them dying that's left
caught up to them and that's a reality
we don't know when we're going to die
def can come at any time so i hummed it
up thank God that you actually you came
back and you tained your desires yeah
and you start doing it living life the
right way so that's something my next
question what advice do you give for
people like let's say the former UFC
fighter Gordon relic you know after
explaining the purpose of light to them
it's not just makes sense like it did to
you and you know all the millions of
people that are accepting is the
fastest-growing way of life worship the
Creator not the creation do good live a
good life and at the end you got
paradise you're not just living for this
material world and it gives you the
blueprint on how to live from A to Z
everything's laid out and there is no
monkey business there it's not something
that you have to do a whole bunch of
mental gymnastics
to make it fit it goes with the human
soul with the mind so he accepted it
right and so many other people are
accepted it but now the challenge is you
know family culture the desires what
advice do you give to someone like
himself and other peoples who also
they've come to Islam but you see them
kind of drifting off what advice do you
have for me I think some of the the best
advice you can get is that you know the
concept of worshiping Allah alone that's
something that's easy to do but when it
comes to how do you apply it you know
how you apply it following following the
rules that first might look a little
strange to you like growing the beard
like other aspects you know a lot of
commanded us to do certain things and
sometimes they may not look natural to
us but we find out later 1400 years
later scientifically it's proven you
know growing the beard is now healthy
for you we're finding this out finding
out about sleeping on your right side as
opposed to your left side that that has
a benefit to your heart nobody knew that
back then but these are things that are
law and his messenger so I saw them
brought to our attention things that can
guide you throughout your life and they
can preserve you and also they combined
with your existing culture they fix the
problems you had you know things like
drinking and falling into fornication
and stuff like that they they complement
the good qualities of your culture and
you can build that all together and you
can you know you purify yourself and for
the other bin the last minute we have a
lot of the other let's say Serbians or
Croatians let's say you know the Dean
show now reaches that part of the world
and they're like yeah it makes sense I
want I want to live my purpose you know
worship to create a not the creation and
and and live this good holistic life
this life of Pete that brings you peace
and happiness in this life in paradise
in the next but now they're stuck to
that like okay it's separating religion
from my nationality so now it's like I'm
Greek and Greek Orthodox Christian and
you can't separate the two and if I
become a Muslim it's like you know I'm
going to be outcast what would you say
to them I would say that's extremely
common because the vast majority of the
people their faith is tied into their
culture so holidays you know everything
in there
is tied into the previous religion when
you become Muslim you still show respect
to your family you still have the best
of manners with your neighbors and you
should actually go above and beyond what
you did before it's the concept of who
you worship now and following the
religion of Islam they shouldn't cut you
off from them that should make your
relationships better and just like the
prophets themselves have many many
hardships from their families your
examples in the crime your example is
from the Prophet Mohammed and newer and
Abraham all of them had difficulties
with direct family members yeah so all
these things happen to the prophets
before us yeah and that's the test of
life that's right to see who we love the
most if we love our Creator we're going
to obey Him and do all the wonderful
things that he's told us to do we
started with peace we I'm with peace
time flies when you have a fun thank you
so much for being with us here nadine
shekel okay oh yeah peace be with you
something wonderful story here with
Christopher sharing it with us someone
who accepted what's in everybody's
nature to give birth what's inside it's
inside of you you just have to bring it
out and that's the realization that I
have to acknowledge that look someone
created me it was an accident that I
just popped up in this world and the one
who created me that's the one who I want
to worship along without any partners or
associates and what really I think
helped me and so many people when you
really ponder and think about the
destroyers the destroyer of all
pleasures and that's def and I'll leave
you with something to really think about
it's a interesting story where life as
deaf you know why do people love me but
hates you and deaf responded because you
are a beautiful lie and I'm the painful
truth and when you really think about it
you know the human flesh that comes from
the dirt from the clay and it's of the
essence of this world and when we just
feed it with things of the material
existence we see that we at the end you
know we don't end up feeding the soul
and then we just give the flesh what it
needs we become like an animal but the
soul inside every human being it desires
to be
back to connect back with its maker and
then when it's connected back with its
maker that is when you truly feel this
contentment dissatisfaction because a
person can have mountains billions of
dollars of money and houses and cars but
when you're just satisfying the flesh
you're still empty inside and Islam
gives you it's been sent to feed your
soul to bring you that satisfaction that
you need and like to be happy to be
contempt to be satisfied look into Islam
continue to view us here at the Dean
show every week follow us on the Twitter
like us on the Facebook where you can
keep up with all of our updates and make
sure to reach out to the one who created
you and ask him to guide you if you're
tuning in for the first time and he will
definitely facilitate away we'll see you
next time peace be with you